we are indeed with a proud Victor of
today's round elshon moradia body who
took down the Wild Card Warner young
elshon welcome to the show a difficult
game yesterday against Sammy defended so
well but unfortunately fell short today
on the other hand you bounced back in
incredible fashion tell us a bit about
it yeah well I first have to say that I
feel very lucky today at
I misplayed my opening my move eight
eight okay
after okay not eight sorry later on okay
my prep was against against the
was it A4 here I play A4 can you play A4
yeah yeah and that actually is the move
that surprised him actually oh okay that
game you see it's downloaded thrown off
against Marc that was my prep what did I
forget then okay so that's a game in the
correspondence just that guy is a world
champion unfortunately we cannot because
I kind of look at that no we can all
look that yeah at that but yeah so I was
expecting something like 25 perhaps
Knight A5 is not it's not a good move I
know that you should see too even yeah
yeah this is a slightly this is I'm good
here this is I'm good here uh okay so
then I play The Right Move so what are
the ideas behind this movie for because
we were discussing the main line
obviously is D4 so you go A4 a43 weight
and then prepare the move and because
you play the move A4 you have Bishop A2
the whole idea is that you keep the
bishop A2 an option got it so so I'm not
looking at D4 but rather D3 slow you
eventually you want to play default I
mean if you don't play D4 in Spanish and
you play with blacks if there's no
there's no first you get the Knight to G
yeah yeah that is the or even sometimes
after 92 average default so okay I
played the right moment
yeah and uh
I must have didn't analyze this and I
forgot I mean I feel very past three
weeks I had this immune system run down
and I I I don't sleep well so during the
game I expected him to play this I had
looked at this but yeah so I forgot
anyways then I played D3 which is okay
and then yeah Knight A3 that isn't the
greatest one okay I didn't like to smoke
C5
this move C5 uh I think Knight G5 right
maybe it looks that's a nice nice C5 for
him instead we'll go back in ic5 oh
engine relax this for white yeah Knight
E6 then still seems to be favorable and
before yeah this this
postponing works yeah yeah because now
he doesn't have the right setup with the
organized to go Pitch Perfect
makes a lot of sense so c5s was a good
move
Bishop G5 engine oh wow this that's that
guy is actually actually correspondence
player it seems like you guys are still
following something on this game wow I
did not know so okay
and uh and he played Queen B6 which
already seems to be the what we were
discussing this that's why I was lit I'm
sorry we were discussing this move that
I said I'm not a big fan of this move at
all because you let go of the five score
kinda kind of but I thought Bishop C6 is
a better move instead of Queen B6 okay
Bishop to C6 that's apparently been
played yeah and then I was going to
explain that C2 Knight E3 and then
probably Knight d293 trying for D5 at
five square it's there's very minimal
but I mean it's normal just a normal
position normal Roy Lopez uh and he
played Queen B6
yeah I thought this was probably this
was very concrete really that was his
plan
yeah I think it's already really bad I
don't know I mean your engine doesn't
show a lot of advantage for me I think I
think that's okay
yeah but no nice if I was definitely
losing I mean he missed A5 he said after
the game Knight C5 takes on F6 and then
A5 and uh yeah he missed this one and
now Knight to E3 oh I wish Bishop it was
a stronger pretty much taking over okay
all right 0.3 yeah not a big difference
yeah okay 93
then okay I was playing just right about
and I'm winning and I was cruising and
yeah
I'm playing really well
I'm making All the Right Moves keep
going yeah there's nothing much to say
and then okay keep going here this 23
now it's all all yes all good good still
good still good
and then I thought
and then here unforgivable from me just
take on C5 player V6 I mean just I saw
that during the game I don't know why
yeah it's unforgivable I mean
thank you
yeah I saw it I just said okay I'll give
a few checks
why is it so easy what if you just go
Rook to B6 now Queen to B5 I guess and
then yeah you don't yeah you don't have
time to give uh
both Rooks one Rook for both parts
even instead of uh Knight xc5 I think
that's also winning right
yeah
even easier it does the job yeah for
sure I mean I saw I just yeah and then I
picked up the exchange and then I
realized that if he gives up the bishop
for two pounds yeah yeah and I was like
oh my god
well I mean you deserve it coming when
you play fast huh but you're still
winning
he never had this point you're still
winning but I had to find this one
because I had to find it that I get my
queen right right for V6 when he's not
in time to stop E6 and
and as I said I I'm I'm not feeling so
well but so yeah I
and you're talking about this point yeah
and then finally yeah okay yeah I mean
the more important if you go back a
couple of moves is that this is the
moment for Queen A4 because not if it
goes
rookie five not having time to play
Queen B3 Bishop B6 and now the queen
goes to C6 with the check and then and
then I'm in time finally yeah I was
trying to drag the king to F6 so that I
can have this Tempo to go check on F3
and go to C6 that's a very nice nuance
excellent game uh elshon congratulations
and also uh Sabina you are the coach of
Sabina still yeah
we prep a little bit at night
um but again I have to do my own
preparations I mean in the mornings she
she has her own files I have to check my
own files and then we play accordingly
and stuff so absolutely congratulations
thank you Sean we'll see you in the next
few rounds quick question for you elshon
uh first of all congratulations for your
Victory very nice uh and you're of
course coming into this tournament with
this big Target on your back you're the
lowest rated player in the field
how does it feel uh knowing that
everybody's gunning for you is it a good
feeling or a bad feeling yes yeah I have
a good feeling about about having a
Target on your back coming into this
event as the lowest rated player I think
I started getting used to it so
that's okay I'm I mean once in a
lifetime it happens to you so
that's okay
yeah
excellent It's a Long Way to go so the
the more Targets on my back so yeah
Anastasia you had the question I just
want to say that so far so good so far
so good luck in the rest of the journal
we'll be fine thank you so much
carefully uh turning to the remaining
game for just a moment we got Arena
Crush for